see I knew you'd be back cuz you got
nothing better to do now you come over
here and do something for your instead
click the link below and establish the
house of Allah get yourself a house in
Paradise with a superb high
level for yourself that will continue
inallah click the link
below we haven't spoken about jewishness
and Judaism enough and the reason why is
because we've been afraid to be called
anti-semitic but today after drink this
cup of water everything's going to
change I know there's somebody some guy
from The Secret Services
here saying Okay
now what's a what's a famous like a
Norwegian name give me a
name give me give me one
lar yeah there's been enough lares I've
had to deal with in my life said L we've
got him now he said he's going to be
anti-semitic I don't know why he's got
this kind of accent anyway but I can't
do the Norwegian accent it's very
difficult to
do if I tried to do it would probably
sound like a
German
anyway Islam deals with Judaism as a
religion and there's lots of
aat and this is actually I know this is
going to go online this is my message to
the
Jews
and you know we're coming for you know
only I'm only kidding I'm only
kidding no on a serious level because
Judaism is seen as two things at once
it's seen as it's an ethnicity and it's
seen as a
religion so I'm not talking about the
ethnicity although that has some bearing
of what I'm about to say one of the main
things about Judaism as a religion is
that they do believe that this group of
people this tribe of people are the
chosen people they believe in that and
the Quran challenges this all the
time if you truly believe if you truly
believe that you are the chosen people
and it's mentioned twice by the way one
in bak and the other one is in chapter
62 of the Quran if you really believe
you the favorite people that Allah has
chosen then go ahead and ask for death
now you might think why is Allah saying
this because if you're the the favorite
person and there is some level of
afterlife which they believe although
they don't spell it out by the way
Jewish people don't have Heaven and Hell
this might be very surprising to you
like they might have some level of
conception of the afterlife but they
don't have Judaism doesn't have like in
Christianity in Islam Heaven and Hell it
doesn't have
this Subhan Allah by the way
interesting which is why the Quran it
actually uh criticizes this
and this is Allah is saying this about
Jews and and polytheus you'll find them
the most cautious about preserving their
life so say Allah's saying this
Quran is saying that they wish to live a
thousand years and he cannot live A
Thousand Years
and he's not going to be able to Swerve
the punishment if you live for thousand
years that's what Allah says in the
Quran so you I've find this very
interesting because I've been attacked
on this basis I had this debate with
this guy called unho
shoi and he were saying like you guys
want to die you want to die it's yeah I
don't see why this is a criticism we
believe in an afterlife yes we believe
in Jenna in fact you should want to die
calm down calm down calm down it's just
a break I'm reminding you that when you
are finished watching the video huh that
you click the link below and donate
now that Allah is saying effectively if
you believe if you believe you're the
chosen one you don't really need to do
much you're a Chosen One by accident of
birth you're the chosen guy you're the
one Allah you're so special Allah chose
you so you really believe this then why
you why you hearing this dun outside in
the minus 20° and this one and that one
and why are you living this life there
must be something better waiting for you
if I truly believe this I'd every day
say let me die let me die let me die I'd
even be going around the highways like
this because the thing is why am I this
the dun is is test is pain is part
things if you Allah is saying if you
really believe this about yourself and
you really believed in some level of an
afterlife then should want
death but then Allah says something
else there two verses they don't and
they won't ever ask for
that because of what their hands have
put
forward that's what Allah says they know
ask for that so yes the Quran does speak
to the Jews directly it speaks to the
bani is it says there was a time
yeah
for example that you were chosen at one
point in time you were chosen when you
chose Allah that's when you were chosen
this is not the Quran this is me making
a distinction people are chosen on the
basis of them choosing
Allah when they swerved Allah swerved
their
hearts you are chosen in as much as you
choose Allah you are
chosen and you can still be
chosen and this is my message to J you
can still be chosen the the Quran is
giving you is extending the Olive Branch
to every Jew in the world you can be
part of this
community
yes you can be this is what Allah he's
telling us in the
Quran that there's something more but
then the question
is if your belief is one which is in
encourages preservation of life at all
costs and our religion is not that like
that and yes preservation of life is is
important but preservation of religion
is more important and there's a concept
of martydom then I would consider that
to be an advantage
frankly because as Robert Green said the
one who's willing to commit suicide has
the initiative now I'm not saying commit
suicide anyone this how we got him here
not talking about suicide mission here
bro I'm just saying figuratively the one
who's willing to take it further so look
I mean I love the fact that you know um
you guys are actually doing things in
English language you're doing things now
you've got people doing things in Arabic
language you've got things do in
Norwegian language you're moving around
Scandinavia now is everywhere I go
honestly I'm not just saying this in
front of the camera W everywhere I go
people know what we're doing here
alhamdulillah Everywhere I Go Everywhere
in Oslo oh you guys have heard Islam net
the center this and that this everyone
knows what's going on here and the
reason why why is because it's really
hit home W I was just speaking to some
guys yeah in the it's true story and
they were telling me that you know what
you guys done with that Quran B last
year it changed the game completely bro
aldah it changed the game it's the
Muslim civil rights initiative and I
love the fact that you guys are doing
that and especially now with the
Palestine cause everyone's in great
solidarity and so I just want to say
that we can see also those elements yeah
who are I would say let's say
antithetical to our cause opposed to us
an anti us that they are starting to get
jealous and
envious yes tell us more about that
because you've been you've been
observing those people haven't you so
you have people any the the Zionist
movement and their their allies they're
trying to make issues they're trying to
even any we received some Terror threats
as well and you went to the police and
the police didn't care yeah and it's
it's quite shocking it's quite
disturbing very disturbing bro so but as
you guys just saw the event
alhamdulillah and it was packed hundreds
hundreds of Muslims are coming and
they're actually you learning about the
religion and they're coming closer to
Allah and they are waking up I think and
that's that's the big thing this is an
Awakening we are Awakening the Muslim
umah and that needs to be done
especially in these kinds of
circumstances we're finding the today
absolutely it is a it has to be an
organized effort and you know what I
think people are convinced now because
they've seen yeah they've seen what it
is this is where there's an electric
environment bro there's a Vibe
everywhere I go in Norway this place
that everyone knows what this movement
is about and so it's time to give
charity it's time to give charity into
an investment that's going to help you
in this the you know and that's what
Allah calls us a goodly loan but also I
was just thinking about this aah Subhan
Allah amazing aah but it shows you the
importance of Charity and sodak in Islam
that when someone when death comes upon
them of allas chapter 63 he's going to
say
what if only you had just let me for
some time so this person's in regret now
and the quran's mentioned this that he
would
say that I would have given
money I would have given charity Subhan
Allah now you have the opportunity to
give charity to one of if not the one of
the most important biggest centers in
the world in the whole world in the da
World which is Islam that because it can
do and say things which by the way
people can't do and say things like this
in the Muslim World censorship this and
that government all those kind of things
this is one of the most fruitful
opportunities of Charity in the entire
world
D all they have to do is click the link
below and I think they will do that bro
I think they
will
[Music]
all